you had this career explosion with
friends meteoric rise to fame but at the
time that you went to audition for
friends you had is this true $11 in your
pocket and that was all you had yeah
well I was almost 11 it was like 10
something it's not a cool story hey when
it's when it's a it's 10 and change or
11 you really hope it was 11 yeah okay
that's unbelievable to me you had no
savings at the time you were he's kind
of a starving actor but to only have $10
in this town that's that's yeah it was
it was yeah I was I'm a procrastinator
it was time to get go and get like a
real job like two years prior to that I
should have gone right got a job doing
something but I just said not all those
big things right around the corner right
right right around this next corner no
not this coin it's that it's the next
step next there's a corner coming up but
you know what so many actors in this
town say that and it never happens and
then for you to say no no it's coming
it's coming and then friends comes yeah
what an amazing thing I just was you
know right place at the right time was
really fortunate you know a gobble
that's yeah what job would you have
gotten do you think if let's say friends
hadn't come along and you just had to
get a job just to pay the rent what
would you have will be your first choice
uh I guess I I would have scoured the
neighborhood for like a construction
crew and got on a customer you just want
to get our another bulldozer yeah well
of course an amazing break and friends
and now you're on episodes I love the
show it's hilarious it's a lot of fun
it's a really funny show and you shoot
the show in London and I'm curious you
must spend a lot of time in London are
you picking up any of the British
phrases over there yeah there's there's
one I've noticed that they use quite a
bit um it begins with a seed then it to
you then it's an end okay all right yeah
okay they use in this gender-neutral
isn't there yeah yeah here you'd never
say that word no no he says that we're
here over there there's hey you know how
you silly and they talk to each other
like like I've heard it used as a term
of an
I've heard of use like in an argument
it's like it's like dude they do I've
noticed that it like dude yeah like bro
yeah well not bro but anyway they they
use that word I've noticed that over
there they say it all the time and if
you're an American it's really shocking
you know and you go over there and you
expect if you grew up watching Mary
Poppins it's all gonna be like ChIP chip
cheerio you know and then you get there
and they're saying the c-word left and
right it's ChIP chip cheerio you even
use that word because it's so common and
you have to these amazing actors on your
program the producers that you're
working with are you a pretty magnet in
terms of they're just absolutely amazing
you have used the c-word on the show
because it's written and it's it's it's
yeah they recover there was an episode
where I called I say it to my ex-wife
the show which which is really funny
because in real life you know I'm you
know I'm playing myself so you're
playing yes you're paying playing matt
LeBlanc weird version of myself so I was
like well better do a little damage
control so I called my ex-wife in real
life and I said hey listen in the show
coming up I called my ex-wife in the
show this word mm-hmm and I say it not
in a nasty way but still it's that word
so and I just wanted to let you know
it's not a dig at you in any way shape
or form god bless her she goes I don't
watch your show
you
[Applause]
you